[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
brilliant Dom we're here here we are in
the Friendship onion Studio not only the
friendship on your studio but our
friendship onion Studio resplendent with
new fanat fanat all over the world
there's a picture above you of Perry and
mipin there's you as Captain Jean-Luc
Picard well I would be wonderful yep
there's a kind of an anime tribute to
the four Hobbits here the stick drawings
it's lovely onions we're running out of
space because I there's a I don't know
where to put this one which is my
favorite out of the fan arts I do enjoy
that one very much we're just trying to
figure out where to put that I might
might just have that there just at all
shapes that was when we had the the side
cameras for a building don't meet the
world I want them back I want them back
too hold on I'm back you look handsome
what have you been up to this week
anything uh interesting to report it's
sharp them aren't they yeah I keep doing
that was this part of a sword cult is
that the hilt well done done take it
right up to the hilt exactly yeah
um
what's been happening this week not a
lot really I bought oh God I bought a
new uh Hoover no uh uh spatula colander
no sieve no is it for the kitchen no
yeah is it
force it it goes outside dog something
happens inside near the kitchen I'm up
and then it goes outside it goes outside
why because it stinks a bin no uh
compost no uh fridge uh fridges don't
tend to go outside sometimes they're
empty and when they're empty they're of
no use ice ice cleaner ice box yeah hang
things on it a maiden a washing Maiden
what's that is that what it's called was
that washing Maiden I think that's what
my mother calls it hello Maureen hello
Maureen that you put your washing on to
dry yeah okay a closed horse a clothes
horse nice I bought a new one okay what
happened to the old one destroyed by
your duck I washed my uh I washed my uh
sleeping bag
why are you going camping I don't know
maybe that's a strange thing well I must
get that washed I rinse that are just
very very simply
and uh but when I got it out the bath
where I washed it and it weighed up tons
of they've made some terrible decisions
this way and I put it on the coach horse
in the cruise horse like an old horse
would his legs just went woof from out
from under him well I could imagine it
was like a 75 pound sleeping bag when it
came out the bath it weighed that I mean
it was a lot but so I had the normal
horse that went up like to a point like
uh you know
a triangle an actual Horse no the the
coast horse went like that but I got a
new one it goes like that but also it's
got wings that come out like that oh
lovely a lot more room I put a big load
on this morning
oh ducks and I hung it and I took every
single inch of space on this thing wow
now is that outside or in So yeah so
it's for the drippage getting a bit of
air about it yeah nice that's natural
that isn't it I still can't solve the
conundrum of uh how to not have my
clothes smell Frosty did we talk about
this do you think it's it because I
don't get that
but do you have as many t-shirts as me
no I don't think so I rotate you rotate
I would say probably 15 to 20 backs
right at the most I mean have you ever
seen me in this t-shirt before yeah I
saw you uh online with that t-shirt on
oh yeah well that's kind of
yeah okay
it's nice but not often it's a big dog
it's a big Doberman isn't it yeah it's a
Doberman Pinscher yeah
um my thing is because I have a lot of
t-shirts I won't get round to wearing
the same t-shirt for probably
six months maximum minimum minimum
minimum maximum minimum minimum and when
I put it on even though it's clean and
it's come out the washing machine and it
smells like you know fluffles or
whatever yeah it now smells a bit fussy
like a second yeah you should get that
maybe someday out there and the
friendship onion Universe can help us
because I would think
it's not going to start unless does your
um
does your uh
closet smell
no I wouldn't say anything like if you
took all the clothes out yeah does my
closet smell of tuna fish or something
like that no it doesn't smell of
anything so where's it picking up the
smell I don't know I don't know is it
damp in your house
no
it's a mystery
but if anyone knows someone said to me
well we went for dinner the other night
and someone said have them be all dry
cleaned and then individually put in
plastic and I said well there's no way
I'm gonna do that well it's not like
you're a high-end t-shirt store and also
it's only good once when it's encased in
plastic that thin that plasticy stuff
maybe it's good then but then as soon as
you take it out it's not good again but
like I don't have as many t-shirts as
everyone else let's say let's take for
instance someone who is a little bit of
a style icon David Beckham he probably
has hundreds if not maybe even thousands
of items of clothes if he doesn't wear a
suit for a couple of years when he goes
to take it off the hanger again is it a
bit Frosty well there's a good point
no I've got six yeah I don't wear but
when I put them on they don't smell
thirsty
first day first day
what do you call it Frosty Frosty but I
like it fisty fisty fisty uh lovely if
you do know if you do know why cause
would smell
for no other reason yeah just the line
around not lying on hanging hanging
hanging about
oh I would think it has something to do
with something for sure good I'm glad we
cleared that up um it's been quiet on
the Riff this week as well hasn't it
we've not really there's not been much
going on I tried the new champion who
with you who I don't know she was down
in bottom Lane oh Samira what a night
very difficult well the thing about
Samira which we all
had to endure is that you have to be
playing at a very high level for all of
her abilities to unlock yeah that's
rough
I'm gonna start playing Yorick alas at
last periodic
for this either
he
it was kind of he looks like a little
bit of a sourpuss and he's got like a
couple of little like miniony characters
that come out around him to protect him
uh you know kind of like help us
like a little bit like malzaha but then
his ultimate he
um brings forth the maiden this is a
maiden the maiden she's just called the
maiden she's like a ghostly figure that
goes and attacks people for him
our friend Andrew plays uh
you're like oh you played golf with
Andrew how was that it's good
hitting squirrels uh no but I did I did
see uh
a dead pigeon oh do you think I've been
hit by a golf ball yeah I think so do
you it was very fresh oh that's a shame
yeah any did you see any injuries on it
do you see a golf ball nearby no no wow
hereby golf yeah it would just it was
just nine holes and I was I was very
Rusty fussy but do you play Mike's golf
not really you know but you played a
little I played a little with you I'm
not good and it's that we were when you
when you go you swing you feel as if
your body's forgot how to swing a golf
club tight and you just go that was ugly
it just felt ugly I'm sure it looked
ugly but it was fun out of the three of
you would you put yourself in third
much better Jack no no it was like um I
think it was two strokes
we're all about the same to me right
it's nice when you play with people with
the same the worst is playing golf for
someone who's excellent and then he or
she gets bored that you're kind of
dragging your feet and you're like well
there's nothing I could do this is going
to be uh 17 shots together in the hole
another guy came around with us that's
the only thing that's one thing I don't
really like about golf is people can
just join your gang oh what did he just
say would you mind well if it's it's
normally four you go around in four four
it's all fours and golf and uh if you
haven't got your four like us we had the
three and we were just teeing off and
the guy from the you know who's running
the course said uh this is Zach he's
going to join you on the uh
you're like
don't bother yeah but you can't see that
Zach can't go around on his own can he
no so the the led him to whoever's got a
three it's fair enough because if you
think about his shoes on the other foot
if you're in Mexico yeah is that me
Amigo Billy yeah but I would I would
rather grow myself but they won't let
you because then you're holding up the
whole thing aren't you well how good was
Zach it was actually all right he was
probably I would say the same as us
again nice everybody was about the same
well that's lovely when that happens
can we talk about notifications for a
second why not I know it's the other
night when I was at your house you have
the little clicker on your phone when
you're typing I don't care who's that
for me to know that you're typing yeah
mine's completely silent who leaves
those sounds on anymore I guess maybe
you well apart from this sound
ah yes another sale on Spotify the only
one Commerce platform to start run and
grow your business Shopify makes it
simple to sell to anyone from anywhere
whether your thing is vintage t-shirts
or recipes for ghee start selling with
Shopify and join the platform
simplifying commas for millions of your
favorite businesses worldwide with
Shopify you'll create an online store in
your Vibe discover new customers and
grow the following that keeps them
coming back Shopify has all the sales
channels sorted so your businesses keep
growing from an in-person POS system to
an all-in-one e-commerce platform even
across social media platforms like Tick
Tock Facebook and Instagram and thanks
to uh 24 7 support and free libraries
full of educational content shopify's
got you every step of the way it's why
every minute new sellers around the
world make their first sale with Shopify
and you will too my wife's got a Shopify
business you've met my wife I love your
wife a fantastic Shopify business guy
great t-shirts and some of the best
coffee mugs on the planet and she loves
Shopify set it all up she watched with
it every day I suppose and she thinks
it's fantastic Shopify makes selling
simple so you can put yourself and your
ideas out there whether your thing is
making ebooks or earrings Shopify makes
your success possible when you're ready
to launch your thing into the spotlight
do it with Shopify the Commerce platform
backing millions of businesses down the
street and around the globe go on try
Shopify for free and start selling
anywhere this is possibility powered by
Shopify sign up for a free trial at
shopify.com onion or lowercase go to
shopify.com onion to start selling
online today shopify.com
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big Wireless
providers if I've learned anything it's
that there's always a catch them oh
isn't it always a catch but when I first
heard that mint mobile offered premium
Wireless starting at just 15 bucks a
month I thought well what's the catch I
said didn't I you did actually watch The
Catch but after talking to them and
using the service it all makes sense
there isn't one mint mobile secret sauce
as they are the first company to sell
Wireless
online only they cut out the cost of
retail stores and pass those sweet
savings directly onto you for anyone who
hates their phone bill mint mobile
offers premium Wireless for just 15
bucks a month mint mobile gives you the
best rate whether you're buying for one
or a family and at mint family started
two lines all plans come with unlimited
talk and text plus high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network use your own phone with any
Mobile plan and keep the same phone
number along with your existing contacts
switch to Mint mobile and get premium
Wireless starting at just 15 bucks a
month to get your new Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com that's
mintmobile.com onion cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
well William you've got a fantastic
guest today yes we do Tom someone who
really speaks my language because
English yes and yours too because he
works in
soil ecosystem responses to
climate-driven environmental changes
also evolutionary ecology ecological
genomics soil biodiversity and
microfauna basically the tiny teeny tiny
little creatures that live in between
the teeny tiny little pieces of soil
he's interested in that is it he's
interested it's amazing isn't it the
world how it works it's a big crazy
machine
mined by many many different species
just keeping it going keeping it going
without these little things the big
things won't have anything to eat right
absolutely things won't grow
clean soil fresh air plants grow isn't
that amazing yeah I watched a
documentary on Infinity the other night
so on Netflix you would like it about
our friend Professor Brian Green was on
it talking about the notion of infinity
and what we what we initially thought
was infinite and now what's infinite but
isn't infinite always infinite is it
yeah I think so I mean you'd have to
watch the documentary oh did you watch
it yeah would it is it well they didn't
answer that question what did the answer
we're too busy talking about how
infinite has changed over the years but
I don't think it can change well that's
not what the documentary said you know
at first at first they thought the the
Galaxy stops whatever but then there's
no infinite
it's finished and then they thought no
it goes on forever
and then someone said well
what does that mean if it goes on
forever you'll never reach the end and
then Einstein put forward this idea that
like well no it could be like Earth
where if you keep walking East you'll
eventually come back to the same spot
and go around again and he said maybe
the universe is like that when you get
to what you think is the quote-unquote
end you just come back you come back so
then you have to think of another
dimension
up the way see for instance up the up if
you're only going east with
is it a circular that way as well yeah
it is
you should watch it it's on Netflix
you'd enjoy it something something
infinite or something something Infinity
I'm not sure it's vague I'll try and uh
what that out something something
something infinite yeah I think it's
important use to be infinite I think
it's something like the road to infinity
or the path to Infinity I'll find that
out for you but I'm sure our guests
would maybe have a few things to say we
could maybe ask them about uh the
infinite and also uh he spent quite a
bit of time
yeah studying in the colder parts of the
planet so well let's bring on our guests
yeah why wouldn't we Byron Adams here he
comes
well guys as you know I am a
self-professed
nerd in terms of animals specifically
invertebrates big fan of reptiles I try
and pride myself on being able to at
least slightly know what animal I'm
looking at and if there's ever a quiz
question about animals and I get it
wrong I spend weeks beating myself up
about it so
I'm extremely excited to be joined on
the show by Byron Adams who
is a PhD scientist studying the
creatures that we find in soil generally
is that right Byron
that's right Don now Byron before you
jump into it I'm just going to read a
little bit of your bio because it's very
impressive and it has a lot of very big
words so I'll try my best all right here
we go after completing a Bachelor of
Science is that BS
BS after completing a Bachelor of
Science in Zoology at Brigham Young
University in 1993 Byron earned his PhD
in biological sciences at the University
of Nebraska in 1998 and was postdoc at
UC Davis in 1999 as an assistant
professor in nematology and entomology
department at the University of Florida
Byron talk courses in nematode
morphology and Anatomy computer
techniques in researches and
invertebrate field biology as an
associate professor in the biology
department and member of the BYU
evolutionary ecology Laboratories he
currently teaches bio 240 which is
molecular biology and NM bio 651 which
is co-evolutionary analysis I did not
mess up one word
so Byron you're interested in the very
very small creatures that run the world
is that correct yeah the very small
creatures that uh rule the world I would
say they play super important parts uh
in the planet's uh homeostasis like
keeping the planet functioning yeah a
lot of our planet outside outside of you
know a lot of the ocean uh is is soil
based you know and a huge amount of
creatures live inside that soil it's
generally a lot of animals that we don't
see and unfortunately because of that a
lot of humans just disregard those
creatures but could you talk a little
bit more about specifically the
importance of those animals and why they
run the world for us
yeah so
um first of all you know much of the
Earth's biodiversity is in the soil in
fact it's probably the largest bio
repository of diversity on our planet
and we sort of just walk around on it
Tara incognita we don't really know much
about what's below our feet or how
important it is in general
but those organisms that live in the
soil perform all kinds of really
important ecological processes for us so
like if you're interested in clean water
or fertile soils growing plants and food
bioremediation taking care of pollutants
that we put into the to the soils then
you need to be interested in the
organisms that live there because those
are the functions that they perform for
us so really important lots of
invertebrates obviously quite quite a
number of insects live in the soil but
lots of invertebrates as well are there
any other
types of animals that are enumerate in
the soil because obviously I can't think
of a huge amount of mammals obviously
there's a few that we know of you know
boring rats and mice and things like
that but it's the soil is generally not
full of mammals or Birds it's taken up
generally with invertebrates right
that's right typically mostly taken up
by invertebrates and and they're
extremely abundant and they're just
really small so we don't see them we
don't notice them like we would a mammal
or a bird or even macroinvertebrates
like crickets and Grasshoppers and
things like that yeah
but they're they're incredibly abundant
so they're just nematode worms alone
uh are the most abundant animals on our
planet so if you took all the animals on
the planet all the birds the squirrels
The Grasshoppers zebras and you put them
in a big bag and you shook that bag up
and you pulled out five animals four of
those animals would be a nematode worm
wow and and most of your listeners are
like what's a nematode wow most people
don't even know what those are you know
because they're so small and microscopic
and beyond our view well let's let's
educate them let's tell people out there
what a nematode worm is and why they're
why there are so many on our planet
well so nematode worms are microscopic
round worms so they're not really like
the night crawlers you might see in your
yard those are segmented worms these are
round worms and for the most part
they're smaller than a millimeter long
so a really big one would be like a
millimeter long and they've lived on
this planet for hundreds of millions of
years maybe even billions of years some
of the very first organisms to evolve on
our planet and they have very simple uh
biology very simple design body plans
and that's made them perfect models of
study and so the first animal that was
at its genome sequenced was a nematode
Worm for example wow yeah and and they
specifically eat and and filter through
soil is that what they did yeah so they
perform all kinds of functions in soil
and and some some nematodes they they
just feed on on bacteria right and they
cycle nutrients like nitrogen and carbon
and phosphorus others are parasites of
plants and cause all kinds of human
suffering because you know they're
killing the plants that we want to eat
some nematodes get into our stock
animals or our farm animals our pets
even right or even into humans and cause
big problems right and so they're
everywhere nematodes are everywhere on
the planet if you were to be sitting on
the moon and looking at the planet Earth
and you dissolved everything away except
for just the nematode worms you could
still see the major features of the
planet you would be able to see the
mountains and the oceans and and even
some biogeography you'd be able to see
like where the mammals live based on
where the parasites the nematode
parasites of the mammals are on the
earth that's how abundant and numerous
they are the concentration of the worms
in that area would show that there was a
large animal in on or around that place
this show is brought to you by better
help
unfortunately Dom life doesn't come with
a user manual so when it's not working
for you it's normal to feel a bit stuck
navigating any of life's challenges can
make you feel unsure whether it's uh a
career change a new relationship or
maybe even become an apparent oh do you
know something I don't
therapists are trying to help you figure
out the cause of challenging emotions
and learn productive coping skills which
makes therapy the closest thing to a
guided tour of the complex engine called
you better help has connected over 3
million people with licensed therapies
it's convenient and accessible anywhere
plus a hundred percent online sometimes
you just need to talk to the
professionals you and I have a great
support system we help each other out
but maybe sometimes when you've got a
friend that's so close you might need an
outsider to give more of an unbiased
point of view sometimes you don't want
to burden your friends and you just want
to speak to a professional as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched 3 million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just follow a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
onion that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash onion
Reserve Bar is your online source for
premium and luxury Spirits wine and
champagne and now Reserve Bar offers
same day delivery Reserve Bar has a vast
lineup of rare and hard to find bottles
premium Brands celebrities spirits and
limited releases that you just won't
find in your local store I know no one
does Spirit gifting better than Reserve
Bar you're looking for an elevated gift
reservebar.com has you covered and you
can have that gift delivered right to
their door even better turn that
spirit's gift into a cherished Memento
with custom engraving perfect for
birthdays weddings anniversaries
Father's Day you name it yeah getting
into home bartending Reserve Bar has
everything you need Spirits for the
shells sure but they also have every
barware tool and glass you need Reserve
Bar is a great feature called cocktail
lounge this is a treasure Trove of
cocktail rest bartending tits interviews
with Master distillers celebrities and
more and the hot trending Spirits Billy
is ready to drink cocktails have you
tried them yes they're delicious you're
drinking one right now they taste better
than ever and Reserve Bar has a huge
collection of them these canned
cocktails are great for parties when you
don't have time to tend the bar or for
tailgating season which supposedly is uh
fully in swing right now Reserve Bar
also has barware glassware cocktail
recipes and more need something for a
party tonight Reserve Bar now offers
same day delivery straight to your door
did you forget that special birthday
gift Reserve Bar to the rescue with
same-day delivery visit reservebar.com
today and use promo code onion to save
ten dollars off your purchase of 75 or
more on Spirits wine or pre-made
cocktails but only when you use our
special offer at reservebar.com with the
code onion that's reservebar.com and
code onion this offer expires December
31st 2022
which I'm fascinated with people who are
for the most part just generally scared
of animals and I I start to point out
that not only are we animals and we are
part of the natural world but that also
we we are around animals all the time
they're in our beds they're in our
fingernails they're in our eyelashes
they they live with us and if we did not
have animals around us we would be dead
relatively quickly you know so this this
idea that nematode words are so
innumerate that you know they dominate
the animal world is something that
people need to kind of just latch onto
and be okay with because it's not
changing anytime soon you know
it's not and like you said exactly like
you said you don't want it to change
right like if they're gone we're in big
trouble right well let's go back Byron
if I may because we we always like to
find out the origins of of people's
interests because maybe there's someone
out there listening that is fascinated
by soil or fascinated by biology or or
anything for you in your formative years
you know between the ages of kind of
seven eight nine ten eleven type thing
were you fascinated with animals were
you fascinated with animals that lived
in the soil where did this Fascination
come from for you I was fascinated with
animals at an early age I grew up on a
very small farm in a really rural area
where we had cows and ducks and sheep
and rabbits and goats and everything on
our farm and so I got to be around it I
got to be around them I get to see
biology life animals everywhere that I
was and and so that was you know during
my formative years was uh really
influential on my trajectory but you
know at the time right I wasn't really
into soil animals uh my father was a
scuba diver like a like what we would
nowadays call dinosaur divers so like
this is the 1950s and the 60s you know
they would get their equipment at the
Army Navy store and you know people
along the coast would line up and just
watch these crazy people going into the
water and scuba diving and stuff and so
I was raised in that environment so so
not only did I learn the farm stuff but
also the ocean and the marine animals
and those sorts of things and so that
was really influential in my interests
in in biology and and into the study of
animals as well yeah so that got me
going and then when I got to University
you know it I just always thought if you
love biology if you love animals your
only career options are like medicine or
or you know maybe if you're lucky you
could be a veterinarian or something
like that or if you're really lucky you
could have your own animal show right
like crotch creatures or Marlin Perkins
or something like that right and uh it
wasn't until I got to University where
I'm taking these courses that I realized
oh man the the world of animals is much
bigger than I ever thought it was and uh
and the way that you know you could get
paid to actually study these things and
I was blown away I was like yeah that's
the gig for me so that's how I started
down an academic path nice and and
obviously you know with these with these
university studies that take place and
and you know further education that goes
on with with phds and Masters and all
that kind of stuff generally it is to
serve the human species by studying
these creatures or studying these these
environments so specifically with you
studying the invertebrates that live in
the soil is that so that we can try and
have healthier soil try and have
healthier land for us for the for the
human animal yeah often you know we we
pursue knowledge just for the sake of
knowledge right we just want to know
more we want to know more stuff but as
it always works out knowledge is very
much empowering right and it and the
more we understand these organisms and
their functions in the soil it turns out
it's it's allowing us to address a lot
of really important problems that we
face with our things like soil fertility
and and primary production like just
growing food right in in terms of you
know meeting growing demands for the
number of people that we need to feed on
this planet and being able to deal with
the you know the the pollution that we
face and and those sorts of things and
so a better understanding of what these
organisms are and what their functions
are in the soil are are starting to
illuminate uh their importance and and
help us to understand how we can be
better stewards how how we can treat the
soil manage the soil manage our
ecosystem so that they can be healthier
and more productive
and at this particular Junction that
we're at in in human evolution
where would be classically the
healthiest soil on the planet and where
would be the soil that is in most need
of
some help yeah this is this is an
interesting question and it gets at some
of the topics you've uh talked about on
some of your other podcasts right about
like what's good and what's bad or
what's healthy or what's unhealthy right
what's a good insect versus a bad insect
and you know right we have to put that
into context you know it's like you know
what's good for one thing might be bad
for another but in general like our most
fertile places that we can grow food you
know humans really have have uh hammered
those areas really hard and
um and we have degraded our soils in
these areas and so it's only now that
science is starting to catch up with
that and we're coming up with ways that
we can you know better take care of our
soils but you know in terms of like like
human evolution and where we've lived
before and where we've been able to
build our our societies and our
civilizations I mean almost every you
show me a civilization that has
collapsed and I can show you a
civilization that is not taking care of
its soil resources right almost every
single time you look at a civilization
that's collapsed it corresponds with
degradation of their soils and and their
ability to sustain their population
right these disappearing communities of
people that seem to have vanished
overnight when we look at them through
history like you said that it's either
the water is run out or the soil is is
something that has now been tarnished
they can't plant their their crops there
anymore
um yeah fascinating I mean obviously
humans have spent a lot of time living
next to huge bodies of fresh water
because that's helpful and also at the
base of uh volcanoes because that
creates fertile so initially but as
you've said if you're farming that soil
over Generations sooner or later it
becomes depleted and that's why now you
have kind of fallow land that gets left
for a few years so they can come back to
it huh
yep that's right yeah so we're starting
to learn more about practices that we
can engage in that will better retain
our nutrients and our soil and the
structure of the soil without leeching
it out to the oceans and then those
those nutrients that are great for our
soils end up really messing up our
waterways and so being able to to keep
our soils intact and prevent soil
erosion ends up being an important
mitigation strategy
so you must spend a lot of time in your
day looking through a microscope since
so many of these animals that you're
studying are
barely able to be seen by the naked eye
right yeah I spend some time looking at
them under a microscope but in the last
10 or 20 years or so we've spent a lot
more time looking at them at like their
genomes and their DNA sequences and
things like that and and you know the
the the the impact that they have on the
soil chemistry the geochemistry and that
kind of stuff but yeah yeah I spent a
lot of time but behind a microscope
particularly when I'm in Antarctica you
know collecting the the animals there
and identifying enumerating deciding
which species they are and and that sort
of stuff
I have a microscope at home too you know
I was brought up my dad was a
science teacher
um and my brother continues to be a
science teacher and we here and there
throughout our childhood we would have a
microscope in our house maybe our dad
would bring back a microscope for the
summer holidays or for the Christmas
holidays and uh I still have that now in
my house it's on my dining room table
guaranteed if I see an animal that a
small animal that I've not yet seen dead
before because I've seen it I've seen
dead bees so many times I don't I don't
pick up dead bees anymore but if I'm
walking to my car and I see a dead
invertebrate I'll usually just put it in
the in the queue in the line next to my
microscope for something to look at for
me it's like a little
little game of being an animal detective
which I've always kind of enjoyed not
only am I
hoping to maybe come up with a
hypothesis as to how that animal might
have died but maybe what actually killed
that animal or what ate that animal
based on you know I avoided the the
crunchy legs and went straight for the
kind of soft body parts or sometimes you
know it's been broken apart into into
different pieces and I just I love it's
almost like looking at a crime scene and
you're like okay we have the dead body
and now we go backwards from the dead
body to see what actually occurred like
does it have a disease did it did it die
in the hot summer sun you know I can I
can do that all the time and I generally
do yeah
I love it
well let's talk about Antarctica because
classically
one would think that invertebrates don't
do well in Antarctica but obviously
there are some creatures that not only
do well in Antarctica but you know kind
of flourish there because they don't
have a huge amount of competition so can
you again can you kind of break some of
these myths and tell us what animals
actually do do well in those substances
yeah yeah so one of the myths is that
the entire content of Antarctica is
completely covered with ice and and most
of it is about 98 of the continent is
covered by an ice sheet that on average
is about a mile thick right and at the
South Pole it's two miles thick you're
drilling through two miles of ice before
you hit the dirt below it but the trans
Antarctic Mountains run across that
continent and they prevent the ice sheet
from coming over the other side of the
mountains and so on the leeward side of
the mountains you've got these large
ice-free areas and then sort of dotted
around the continent you've also got
some areas that are ice free where you
have soils you have open soils and there
are organisms that live there you know
and things like tardigrades and
nematodes codes and up in the peninsula
area even have some insects that are
there but the biodiversity is extremely
low there are very very few animals that
can live in Antarctica now I say animals
in Antarctica most people they think oh
like I know like penguins man and seals
and killer whales and and that kind of
stuff and and I'm like yeah nah those
are all cool but they all live in the
ocean those are marine animals and so if
we're talking about the charismatic
megafauna of Continental Antarctica
you're talking about microscopic animals
that mostly live in the soil and these
these animals have persisted there for a
long time so originally people thought
oh with it with the ice ages that
continent was completely covered with
ice and so all of these organisms that
live there had to have recolonized that
continent in the last 15 000 years or so
and those of us who study these animals
and look at them and we understand their
evolution we're like yeah that's a
totally bogus idea like like these
organisms are are endemic they evolved
to live here a long long time ago and
they've somehow been able to survive you
know these glacial cycles and these
crazy cycles of extreme cold and and Ice
Mass on the continent but yeah so these
organisms are adapted to live in these
really cold dry nasty environments and
they're super tough they can survive
their cells being frozen like a popsicle
and then come back alive when they thaw
out they can be frozen to a crisp like
freeze-dried to a crisp and then you add
water and they come back alive again and
so in that sense those are some of the
adaptive strategies they have to survive
in such a harsh harsh area
yeah so we hit we hit upon the nematode
were uh a while ago but the tardigrade
which has obviously picked up quite a
bit of momentum in the world's media as
being quote unquote the world's toughest
animal and all this kind of stuff can
live in the Great expenses of of uh
solar system and you know can get put
into a microwave you can hit it with a
hammer all this kind of stuff some of
that might not be true some of it could
be uh moving into folklore but so it the
the common name for it is is it the
woolly bear is that what you guys yeah
the water bear we call it or like water
or water piglet they look like right
Little Pigs crawling around in your dish
yeah a squishy little face right with
like rudimentary leg type appendages
um and um they they have been on this
planet for a long long time without
having seen to evolve too much because
they haven't needed to right they've
perfected what they need to look like
yeah they haven't had to add much to
their repertoire right and and the same
and and you know they get a lot of press
for being super tough but they're in the
same class with nematodes and rotifers
they're all able to survive you know
about the same types of environmental
insults and they've been around a long
time they've yeah they evolved these
mechanisms a long long time ago and it's
not just the animals in our Antarctica
that can do this I mean the animals
outside the nematodes and the tartar
grades the rotifers that live in like
hot deserts and cold deserts and other
places are also able to to do this sort
of stuff it's just that the ones that
that survived in Antarctica sort of like
up to their game a bit and can can do it
at a more extreme level
it's a it's a much harsher environment I
mean there are some amphibians that that
can you know get frozen into blocks of
ice and come back right but it's
probably not quite as Extreme as
Antarctica these animals have obviously
evolved to be able to sit in a in a
space of kind of stasis for a long long
time until the temperatures become in
some way more manageable when you said
they that you can freeze them into you
know a block of ice like a like a
Popsicle or or freeze dry them when you
guys are studying them at that
particular point
is it when you're watching them are they
essentially asleep or are they still
going through you know are they eating
are they breathing are they moving or
are they just Frozen they're just
they're in what we call like suspended
animation they they've gone into a state
of uh like crypto biosis we call it or
or when they're dried out we call it
anhydrobiosis life without water and so
they're just in suspended animation and
they can survive in that state for long
long periods of time and then uh yeah
you just provide uh you know liquid
water and they come back alive again and
and and they're active again
how quickly is that process if you've
got a tired of grade that's frozen and
you then introduce some liquid water to
it will it will it start to show signs
of life within a couple of minutes or is
it hours uh it's between minutes and
hours yeah it's it's it's really fast
and it just totally blows my mind every
time I see it right because I got these
in my freezer you know and some of them
are like 15 20 years old and I I pull
them out I I warm them up add liquid
water and you just watch them slowly
come back alive again and it's totally
it's totally the coolest thing
they must be they must be starving at
that point what does a tardigrade
generally eat is it soil matter
vegetation yeah so the ones that we
study uh they eat uh bacteria mostly we
think and maybe you know yeast cells and
stuff like that microbe they're
microbivorous they they crawl around and
graze on bacteria that's growing in the
soil environment for the most part some
of them are predators some of them can
eat other micro invertebrates small
animals but the the majority of the ones
that we study in Antarctica they're at
the very top of the food chain and
there's nothing else that eats them and
they eat bacteria and so you can see
it's a very simple simple food web
if if you're watching the average
nematode worm or tardigrade that isn't
going through this this kind of uh
crypto hibernation what is their General
life cycle that they that they would
have in in a normal life yeah so you
know like outside your window there in
the park if you had a handful of these
these animals you know every their life
cycle you know every three weeks they
would probably go from egg to adult and
have like hundreds and hundreds of
Offspring and that would be their their
life cycle two to three week life cycles
when it's you know summer time in
Antarctica you know we get liquid water
for you know like maybe four five six
weeks out of the year
and so that's just barely enough time
for them to thaw out maybe graze a
little grow a little bit and then they
have to freeze again
and so it may take seven years in
Antarctica them for for them to complete
their life cycle you eventually you know
they get a great summer when they're
mature adults they find females they may
you know and then maybe the next year
they lay their eggs and then the year
after that they might hatch so you can
see that their life cycles are greatly
extended just because of the environment
that they're in
and for you in that environment how
often in the year are you are you taking
field trips to Antarctica so we go to
Antarctica every year so I'm part of a
long-term ecological research project
there that's started before I started
going down there in 1993 and every year
we study how these ecosystems responded
to climate driven changes right so
disturbance is climate and the response
is these soil communities and the
chemistry of those soils and so when I
go down there I'm down there for maybe
two or three months out of the year so
every year I go down there for two or
three months and we collect our samples
and do all our science and our research
and that sort of stuff and then we we
ship we mostly do field work while we're
there and then we ship science the
samples back here to my lab where we do
the genetics and the genomics and that
kind of stuff
right and so how many do you have a do
you have a guess as to how many times
you've been down to Antarctica now yeah
I've been down to Antarctica uh 18 times
I think
nice yeah and if you were to speak to
the Byron that went down the first time
as opposed to the Byron that went down
on the 18th time what have you learned
over that time like were you over
packing the first time were you were you
no did you bring 15 pairs of gloves and
you only really need one like what's
what's changed in that time yeah so uh
the first few times I went down I wasn't
ever certain I was gonna ever come back
again and so I always had to like over
pack and now I've got like a stash bag
that I can keep down in McMurdo Station
so I don't have to package quite as much
stuff back and forth every year I just
kind of keep my big boots and some of
the good extra socks and long underwear
and that sort of stuff down there right
yeah so like in terms of what I've
learned what like what my old knee would
say to my new me
is you know I'm glad you asked that
question because I think I'm still just
as Blown Away by how amazing it is to do
research down there now as I was then
and now it was then I didn't know what I
was doing until I actually got my boots
on the ground and started looking at
these ecosystems and it was it was just
amazing like mother nature had done this
incredible experiment by controlling for
biodiversity but like like out outside
your office there a handful of soil
would have like maybe 30 40 species of
just nematode worms and hundreds of
thousands of individuals and and in
Antarctica it's you got like one two
three species of worms you know and just
and abundance is really low there's no
plants above ground to mess up what
happens in the soil you know plants take
stuff out of the atmosphere they pump it
in the soil it makes it it complicates
complicates things and in Antarctica you
know Mother Nature controlled for that
and so well the first time I got down to
Antarctica I looked around I just saw
testable hypotheses everywhere I looked
it was it was total brain can Andy for
science nerds and and it continues to be
that way so
that's great and then obviously we in
the last kind of 25 or 30 years or so we
have
pushed quite heavily this idea of
climate change and you know the the
significance of what humans are doing to
change the the environment on our planet
it is quite profoundly felt and seen in
the polar regions because you know as as
you said there's not a huge amount more
there apart from massive amounts of ice
which is you know depleting at an
accelerated rate 18 years ago when you
went down there what are you now seeing
uh that you can very accurately
attribute to climate change yeah that's
a great question a sad one as well yeah
it's a sad one but but we were lucky to
be in a position that we could
anticipate we could make predictions
about what we thought would happen with
climate change and we could set up
experiments and we could set up for
monitoring experiments where we could
then test these hypotheses and so one of
the things that we predicted was that as
it gets warmer and wetter that some of
these animals that like it warm and wet
are going to increase in abundance and
expand across the landscape and then the
animals that like it cold and dry and
harsh and salty they're they're going to
become less abundant and they're going
to contract their their ranges across
the landscape and you know you look at
our our data and that's exactly what
we're starting to see we're starting to
see these big changes in the structure
of these communities across the
landscape in response to these climate
driven changes and and then you know as
those organisms change their abundance
and their distribution I mean you can
think about their functions right what's
their function in those ecosystems and
that changes the functioning of these
ecosystems as well so but we're able to
study these in these simple ecosystems
and then hopefully use that information
to scale up right to inform you know how
how we now might understand or study uh
our agricultural ecosystems or managed
ecosystems our natural forest ecosystems
and those sorts of things
and when you're down there you're
staying in a in a field Research Center
is that right yeah there's a field
Research Center so there's a big
commercial station is like a big giant
Flying J Truck Stop kind of thing it's
like a college campus almost and then we
do our field work we fly in helicopters
out to the field and we live in like
smaller remote field camps out there
yeah
the helicopters do okay out there like
the thinness of the air is not something
that they need to be conscious of or you
know they do have to be conscious of
that sort of thing and I'm always amazed
at the skills that these helicopter
Pilots have it just you can see in their
head they're just constantly doing math
making calculations about how much
weight they have and what the air
temperature is and how much lift they're
going to get and that sort of thing that
they do and and of course notoriously
the weather in Antarctica is just awful
and it can you know it can get bad
really quickly and so I'm always like
total respect for the you know the folks
who do science support down there the
the helicopter pilots and the
technicians and those folks yeah
um obviously when you're down there
you're working as hard as you can and
and I'm sure you guys work a lot are
there days where the person who calls
the shots comes to you guys and says and
says unfortunately no one's going out
today it's not possible and if that's
the case what do you guys do instead are
you like really good at Scrabble or like
really good at Tetris yeah so you have
to be really really good at being
flexible MacGyver and things like just
making do and you know we've got so much
work to get done that you know if they
say hey you're not flying to this place
or that place you're staying here today
then we're like cool we can do this and
this and this while we're there and that
that happens pretty frequently like like
daily or like multiple times per day
we're having to adjust our schedule in
response to that sort of stuff yeah
is there a ping pong table down there or
a pool table can you can you guys watch
Netflix like what what do you do yeah so
all of that's available uh but but we
don't do much of that honestly we have
such a short window of time to do the
science mission that we're after and you
know like we tell each other oh we're
gonna just work hard until sundown right
and but you know it's kind of funny
because the Sun never goes down when
we're down there right it's like right
we have 24-hour sunlight and so we just
we we're working so hard we have such a
limited time to collect our samples to
do our experiments and to to to get all
of that stuff done that there's very
little down time and and when when we do
have downtime when when you know when
the weather's bad or whatever we just
adjust and do something else but I will
say you know that you know the folks
that work down there are incredibly
creative they're all artists and writers
and musicians and and a hilarious
brilliant people and you put them all in
one spot and yeah it's it's a magical
place you know so when if you did have
down time and you couldn't do anything
there's something to be done there yeah
right I mean you guys are you guys are
contained so I'm sure obviously you know
you guys come up with stuff because you
know you have a you have a huge amount
of limitations so you're like okay this
is this is a playground this is what
we've got
um that's fun
um how about
any strange phenomena do you have you
seen any bizarre things in the night sky
have you had any close shaves with large
predators do you are there any anecdotal
stories of you know people being chased
by something that you can't quite make
sense of or anything like that
I love this because there is a lot of
really nutty lore out there about
Antarctica and so I always get you know
from the flat earthers they ask me you
know is there really a wall of ice that
like I've flown over the continent you
know as the the Earth is round or
whatever or are there like Nazi cyborg
bases hidden somewhere in the eyes you
know these no-fly zones like like you
know I've been there like no you know
it's all it's all good right um you know
most of the and and honestly we're
really really safe while we're there
like safety is the top priority for
everything that we do people come first
and so there's you know but having said
that it is still very dangerous there
are still people that fall into grasses
and then they pass away or we can't save
them or or people who you know have you
know a heart attack while they're scuba
diving or something and you know they
pass away right so those sorts of events
do happen right but it's very rare and
most most of the time anytime that we're
in danger it's usually weather related
yeah or mechanical related types of
things the most dangerous thing I do
down there probably is just flying
helicopters yes the most dangerous thing
that we do it's like the most dangerous
thing that we do in our day is driving
in our car that's your equivalent of a
car right so and there's an on-site
doctor Hospital type Vibe down there at
all times is that right yeah yeah
there's a there's a small hospital at
McMurdo Station there's a doctor that's
on call there but they have very limited
resources you know they can basically
package you up yeah and hopefully get
you to a trauma center but you know the
closest Trauma Center is in you know
Christ Church New Zealand and you know
that can be from the time you're injured
so the time you get there can be like 18
hours or so so
we go through really strenuous uh
physical qualification tests and stuff
like that before we go down to make sure
that we don't have anything that might
act up while we're there sure and then
we're just really careful while we're
there and you touched upon the the
notion earlier on that you don't have a
night sky because uh the sun doesn't set
over there um no point in the year does
it set or just when you guys are down
there it doesn't set just when we're
down there it doesn't set so the the sun
rises once and then it sets once each
year so it'll rise you know you know in
in this like September September or to
August September October and then it
stays up above the Horizon until like
February March and then it'll go below
the Horizon so you essentially get five
months of darkness and five months of
full sunlight with about a month of you
know
what do you call it like Twilight or
whatever yeah
um and how about things like food is
there any complications with food I mean
obviously if you're eating your food
anywhere near where it's cold you're
going to be in trouble but inside the
center itself you're toasty you're not
struggling to stay warm
yeah so uh in the in our field camps we
have little Huts where we can cook and
keep our food and you know we you know
the all the food that we eat is like
past its expiration date usually because
it comes down you know like a year at
least like the you know the freshest
food that we get is at least a year old
it comes down on a ship the prior season
and and we make do with that it's just
fine you know we get by
um but you do you know when you're cold
and you're working hard you burn a lot
of calories and so we end up eating a
lot yeah
um and there must be I gained about five
pounds a year probably oh nice but like
you said you need that little insulation
because it's so cold down there
um have you guys hosted a lot of film
Crews because obviously there's a lot of
people trying to make shows about the
Antarctic environment
yeah yeah so there are film Crews that
come down logistically it's very
challenging you know like if you wanted
to do a show in Alaska yeah you just
load it up in a van and you drive up
there but you know getting your film
crew to Antarctica is super challenging
because it has to fit in you know along
with uh you know the science programs
and so the you know the the Air Force is
the one that flies us down there's only
so many seats on these airplanes and and
so typically when film Crews come down
they're really much much smaller they're
skilled down they have to be really
Nimble they have to make do with you
know certain the you know that the the
number of people operating cameras and
sound and and producers and things like
that are much smaller than a normal
production would be yeah but yeah they
they come down frequently usually uh
once a year like like they'll overlap
with me in the field sometimes and come
down and and and and I've learned a lot
from them they're super cool folks yeah
I bet
um but I'm sure a lot of those guys are
quite Keen to find some of the
classically easier to
um understand animals whereas you're
leaning towards oh no you should look at
this thing that's you know in inside
inside my hand okay you know
that's true and most of the time they're
like oh yeah yeah cool cool story bro
where's the Penguins right it's got kind
of like that you know these charismatic
organisms that are there but to be fair
like a lot of a lot of the folks who
have been down there you know in my 18
years honestly they really do care about
the science they care about the story
they care about making a difference with
their work and and I really appreciate
that yeah man I mean I think it is a
shame again I'm you know I'm I'm always
trying to help people out with with
understanding the natural world a little
bit more and I I do think it's a shame
that we found ourselves in this position
of saying you know whatever this animal
is good this animal is bad or this
animal is cool this animal is boring you
know even even animals that can very
easily hurt us like lions and great
whites are now at a point of like well
yeah they can hurt us but they're so
cool and they do this and everyone wants
to see them you're like yeah yeah that's
that's a really fun thing to watch an
animal bring down Thompson's gazelle
yeah or you know watch a watch a shark
kill a seal but you know these very
small tiny animals that seem to be doing
little things
universally are doing something profound
and we need to connect to that if if
you're an animal lover I mean almost
almost anyone claims to be an animal
lover this is another thing that I talk
about with people you know most people
it's like saying do you like films
people like yeah I like films Everyone
likes films who doesn't like films you
know if you say do you like animals be
like yeah of course I love animals I
have a dog I have a cat I have a parrot
or whatever
but then my My Vibe with those people is
it's not a selective group you don't get
to pick which animals you love if you're
an animal lover you love all animals you
love ticks you love leeches you love
bats you love slugs in the same way that
we love elephants and gorillas and dogs
and cats you know if you if you're
flying the flag of saying you're an
animal lover then let's let's see it you
know
yeah I love that and think about it if
all we studied were those charismatic
mammals and birds and and reptiles our
understanding of the world our place in
the world would be just you know it
would be so minuscule and and then also
back to the question of like good and
bad you think about the biomedical
breakthroughs that we've had in in you
know genetics in biomedicine that have
come from uh nematode worms for example
or fruit flies you know our study of of
drosophila and those sorts of things
because they're manageable we can work
on them in the lab we can understand
them they're simpler and then we can
scale up to humans we can scale up to to
primates and and use that information to
make a difference and you know if all we
did was just study ourselves and our you
know our dogs and our cats and and
primates and maybe crocodiles and stuff
we would miss out on all of that
absolutely absolutely we would and and
we're also we're all connected you know
we we all all living
animals and and plants and trees and
fungi are all sharing this collected
experience on planet Earth and that is a
beautiful thing to try and connect to I
say that sometimes to people who maybe I
mean I try not to let it happen in front
of me but someone said oh I saw a spider
today and I killed it or right there was
a bee in my house and I crushed it or I
stood on an ant today because it was in
my way and I try and have them connect
to this idea of like that's someone's
son or daughter that is a creature that
is looking for shelter it's a creature
that's looking for food for safety to
get out of the cold to get out of the
roasting hot temperatures they're
telling the same stories that we're
telling we're all we're all someone's
son or daughter we're all trying to stay
safe we're trying to procreate we're
trying to do the right thing and just
because you can kill an animal very
often it doesn't mean that you should
don't get me wrong if I'm in rooms with
no mosquito Nets and a mosquitoes having
a goat me all night there's a pretty
strong chance that I'm going to swat it
but if I have a mosquito net and it
can't get to me I'm going to leave it
alone and let it do its thing this is an
animal having a life experience who am I
to just kill it you know yeah yeah and
we've co-evolved with all of these
animals we have a shared evolutionary
history with so many of these animals
and what we're finding is that as we
remove them from our environment we
suffer right not like our mental health
our physical health suffers as we remove
them from us we try and separate
ourselves from our evolved our
co-evolved natural world and we ended up
being worse off for it you know it turns
out being exposed to some parasites you
know is really good for our immune
system and folks that have you know you
know just take hygiene to the next level
they end up their immune systems end up
suffering because of that I think just
in general I really like the picture you
paint with that that that that that you
know there's this whole planet that we
share with all of these other organisms
and when we try and manipulate that when
we try and change those
ships sometimes it ends up not being
like a great outcome yeah absolutely
well Byron it's been fantastic talking
to you
um we love having people on that come
from a place of passion we love have
people uh having people under obviously
uh enamored with with the natural world
because myself and Billy are too and um
you do fantastic work man and um
good luck to you on your next uh trip to
Antarctica when when do you next go
when's the next uh field trip for you so
next yeah next time I head down we'll be
in early December of this year I can be
down December January February oh so
you're always there over the Christmas
period and you get you guys obviously
celebrate a little Christmasy thing yeah
yeah yeah we do our best to celebrate a
little bit and yeah have a good time
down there fantastic well Byron it's
lovely talking to you
um good luck to you in in your um
your chosen field of study and in life
[Music]
all right take it easy man
[Music]
you're my
[Music]